Hi, everyone, and
I'm very happy
to be here today.
Hope you are enjoying so far
from the different sessions.
This session will
have two parts
jointly given by Szymon Klarman
and myself. My name
is David Amzalag,
and I'm the chief
product officer
of Black Swan Technologies.
Black Swan is
a growing startup
that specialize in data.
We have presences
in six different
countries, more
than two hundred
and fifty employees,
and different type
of customers.
Why different types?
Because every company,
enterprises,
for instance, is having a very
large number of data sources.
Sometimes hundreds
of different
source data sources
and sometimes
thousands of different data
sources that the organization
is relying on and
using him for
all type of usages.
Obviously, regardless
the industry,
those enterprises
are belong to,
health care, finance,
insurances,
retail, etcetera.
What is common
with all of them
is the real and
big concern they
have on how to
effectively manage
all of those data sources,
keeping them synchronized,
accessing them in real time,
keeping the infrastructure not
so expensive, and
very important,
how to monetize
valuable insight
from all of them.
Sounds like a big
problem. No?
Let's make this problem even
more realistic.
Almost all data
sources are feed
by different applications.
Salesforce Salesforce
and other CRMs,
NetSuite, AWS,
Facebook Ministry
of Interior,
etcetera. Those probably are
geographically
spread in addition.
Now what we are doing in many
of the cases is to
build a data lake,
one centralized data lake from
all data sources
that this means
that the data
will be stored at
the same place.
No doubt that this might help
operationally. However,
this is not so
cheap solution,
and data is not
kept synchronized
in many of the cases.
Moreover, once
the data is kept
in a single place,
different personas
of the organization
might have different
usages of the data.
Different queries
might be asked,
and data from
different sources
must be consistent
and aligned.
Actually, a very big problem.
Black Swan created technology
so no data leak is needed,
and access to data source is
done directly to
where they are.
Geography here is
not so important.
Interface is being
done throughout
the no code type of
user experience,
So people from all type of
organizations,
meaning accounting,
hospital data scientists,
investors in bank, etcetera,
will be able to
create applications
and queries by
themselves actually
very easily and
really to generate
insight from the data
with without
being, let's say,
very good software people.
The insight is being generated
continuously
throughout a large
infrastructure of knowledge
graphs and its
generalizations.
Thank you very much for your
time and handing
over to Shiman
to speak about
our interpretation
of knowledge graph.
We call it
the knowledge mesh.
Hi. My name is
Shimon Klarman,
and I'm a knowledge architect
at Dexcom Technologies.
As David already explained,
the main challenge
we are trying
to address is how
to facilitate
utilization of
data within large
data intensive
organizations who
commonly own enormous amounts
of data assets,
and yet they struggle to get
the actual insights
and knowledge
out of those assets.
So a prototypical,
starting point for those kind
of scenarios could
be a use case
we could call a three hundred
sixty degree entity view.
So something, that in practice
would be known as
single client view,
know your customer,
compliance,
a scenario where we want to
gather information
about a certain,
real world entity
or collection
of such entities,
where this information
is actually
spread across multiple data
management systems.
It's well known that in this
kind of scenarios,
organization struggle
with a number of,
data challenges such as data
discoverability issues.
Sources are often based in
multiple even multi
cloud environments.
Because of that,
there's lack of uniform
accessibility rules.
There's a heterogeneity of
database models and schemas,
lack of
semantic interoperability
across those schemas in which
data is expressed.
There's a number
of data quality
issues such as data
incompleteness,
granularity, or
data normalization
issues. Now one,
natural way of handling this
kind of three hundred sixty
degree entity
view use cases is
by employing
enterprise knowledge
graphs. I guess within
this audience,
this is,
this is actually a well
known solution.
We know that we would like to
get the clean,
the duplicated,
resolved, reconciled,
up to date view of
all the entity data.
This kind of entity
and relationship
centric, view is arguably much
closer to the real world or at
least the way we think about
the real world.
It presents all
the information
integrated as it's
a very powerful
data integration
framework under
a single consistent
data model.
Further, this
being a a graph,
also a semantic graph,
which we can explain
a bit later,
means that we can
apply a range
of analytical
techniques on top
of such structure
to get insights,
things like semantic inference
or machine learning
on graphs.
So altogether,
if we add it up,
offers us possibility
to get a reliable
knowledge, something
we can trust,
something that gives us a lot
of contextual information out
of just a plain
raw data source.
Of course, we know where we'd
like to get as the ideal,
end of the journey,
but how to get there
is a challenge
in its own right.
And knowledge
graph construction
process, according to some
textbook recipes, could be,
under some simplification
presented as this kind of,
ETL pipeline going
from the sources
to the final
knowledge graph by
the process of extracting,
transforming, and
loading the data,
most likely to
a graph database.
The extraction process would
most commonly be
achieved using type,
sort of extractors
depending on
the specific data sources.
So for instance,
SQL extractors for
structured databases,
scrapers for, HTML websites,
NLP algorithms for processing
text documents.
The data extracted
from extractor
using extractors would then be
mapped into a target knowledge
graph schema that
we want to use
in the application,
And extraction
results would be
further reconciled, meaning,
quite literally
would basically
connect the dots,
resolve we would
resolve entities
ensuring that there
are no duplicates,
which in the same way would
resolve relationships between
those entities and normalize
the attributes.
At the end of the day,
we would have
a a nice, clean,
consistently duplicated
knowledge graph.
This being an ETL
pipeline, however,
is actually where
big problem is.
Yes. We are getting a nice,
clean knowledge
graph at the end,
but, actually,
it's a knowledge
graph that, again,
is very hard to maintain and
evolve over time,
and it doesn't exactly solve
the data siloing problem that
we wanted to solve
to start with.
Instead, it just creates yet
another data silo.
Now why is that?
Well, if we compare this ETL
approach to some other
known ETL based,
centralized, data
integration platforms,
such as based on the concepts
of data lakes and
data warehouses,
we can see that,
there's a lot of
commonalities.
Okay. The final results might
might look a bit different,
but it's this
centralization of
this whole architecture And,
the the the fact
that the process
is based on ETL,
one directional ETL process,
is what causes the issues.
And the issues are basically,
that we generate a lot of ETL
and ELT code, which,
actually encapsulates
a lot of meaning,
with that we attach
to this data,
a lot of semantics.
And this semantic is only
accessible and manageable for
developers who
build this code.
And the result of it is that
this meaning of data becomes
essentially lost,
and there is no
real end to that
end data ownership,
that would,
allow different,
domain focus teams to be able
to manage and,
govern different data assets
over longer periods of time.
Now what's an alternative?
Following years of experience
with single ad challenges,
we arrived in architecture,
which we call
the knowledge mesh,
which essentially tries to
challenge all
the most important
pain points of those,
previous centralized,
data integration
architectures.
Instead of centralization,
knowledge mesh assumes
a decentralized
data world.
Instead of moving
data to a single
central storage place,
we only virtualize the data at
the query time, at the,
analytic insight
time or put it
generally at
the right time when
the data when the integrated
data is needed.
Instead of developing bespoke
ETL pipelines,
we provide
generic capabilities
driven by metadata,
which can be managed
by nontechnical
subject matter experts.
And instead of focusing on
specific applications
of particular
data assets,
we focus on collecting and
maintaining general knowledge
pertaining to broader
business domains.
So overall knowledge mesh is
this domain
driven architecture
of metadata and
data management
and integration tools,
which are aimed to maximize
the effectiveness of data
utilization in knowledge graph
applications in
different domains.
Let me now walk
you through very
briefly through,
different layers of
this architecture,
to highlight the most
important aspects.
So firstly, there's a uniform
data access and
virtualization layer.
Essentially, data fetchers are
these simple,
services that allow to extract
the data at query time.
They are not basic
they are not
just data extractors
as in this
bay previous ETL,
approach to to
knowledge we have
constructors. They are little
database interfaces,
essentially,
which can take any data source
and expose it using a uniform
data description
language, basically,
a uniform schema
of the source,
and offer a generic
query language,
again, which allows you to
formulate queries
that that are
needed by the application to
satisfy certain,
data requirements.
We use, GraphQL as
this interface,
although, obviously,
this could be achieved,
in number of other ways.
The important part
is that the source,
the the data fetcher
that exposes
the source is agnostic about
the application.
It's the mapping,
explicit declarative mapping
layer that connects
the, the schema,
exposed by the fetcher
to the application
, which provides this essential
glue between the sources and
the application layer.
Now, the one of
the most important,
if not the most important,
aspect of this architecture is
the rich metadata layer.
What is this metadata?
It's basically
the data about,
all the data assets
that are involved,
in the, in the application.
But even more than that,
it's about all
the infrastructural
components that are necessary
to efficiently conduct whole
data integration and data
interpretation
process end to end.
So it's the information about
the data sources,
about the fetchers
that serve them,
about the domains where those
sources are assigned to,
about the mappings,
which map,
the data as served
by the fetchers
to specific domain
vocabularies,
which are also associated with
those domains.
All these components form
essentially a connected
metadata graph,
which provides
a lot of powerful
capabilities to the system.
It allows to catalog different
kind of resources to increase
discoverability.
It opens up a whole
range of, low code,
capabilities,
where we can actually,
instead of writing the spoke,
code support
certain functional
functionalities,
we can offer,
generic solutions which are
consistently driven by this
metadata to achieve certain
goals and support
certain, use cases.
All the metadata
is obviously,
expressed in
standard formats,
standard metamodels,
which further increases
interoperability
between humans
and machine agents.
All the metadata, as
mentioned before,
is, is,
organized in a domain
oriented fashion.
Now what does it mean?
What is a domain read?
A domain is
a predefined collection
of assets that make sense,
and are particularly useful in
the context of some range of
applications which
would jointly,
collect in a in
under an umbrella
of some, business domain.
This kind of business domain
could be a compliance or could
be cyber or perhaps could be
health care. In any case,
a domain consists of a domain
vocabulary. So the collection
of terms which we
use to describe
all important, data relevant
data within this domain.
It contains of a collection of
sources which are
catalogued for
browsing, for discovery.
It also contains
mappings that,
again, generically
map the data
from this domain to the domain
vocabulary and
possibly also a bit,
a collection of of,
domain specific algorithms or
basically some intelligence
which is already built in into
that domain. For instance,
algorithms that can that allow
you to perform
entity resolution
on entities,
within specifically
within this domain.
As a result of of of offering
those kind of of
building those
kind of business domains,
the process of
constructing a specific
application and and,
developing a a knowledge graph
for this kind of
application can be,
to a large extent, automated.
It's, so once the application
is being created in
specific domains,
we can automatically leverage
the metadata, the whole
understanding of which sources
can be used, how they map to
this domain vocabulary,
and how they should,
how the data from
these sources
should be
essentially processed
so that the knowledge
graph powering,
fueling this application,
this domain can be,
constructed relatively,
seamlessly with
a reasonably low
effort from the application
developer.
On the way, we collect we are
able to collect another layer
of metadata. This
is a metadata
about where each data
item comes from.
What do we know
about the source
it came from?
With what confidence and with
what method, this
specific piece of,
data has been extracted,
and how it was
processed later on to,
for instance, resolve,
one entity against
against the other.
All these additional,
layers of metadata
are something
that essentially allows us to
to offer higher
quality guarantees,
to the application consumers.
So this is essentially
the process
of extracting
knowledge from raw
data where
the knowledge basically
comes into the picture
at the moment
where you can start building
trust and start
building confidence
that that the raw data was,
was was was sourced and was
processed in a way
that ensures
high quality information at
the end of the process.
Now when we add these two
different layers of metadata,
which I mentioned,
in the previous
slides together,
the metadata and the data
collected from
the data sources
and the metadata
about the whole
infrastructure,
data integration
we finally obtain this,
this complex twofold knowledge
graph or as it's
sometimes called,
a full data fabric.
It is exactly
the structure that
is necessary for efficiently
utilizing all
available information
and automating all
the data processes,
that we want to,
that we need to carry out in
order to gain insights and get
knowledge out of
the originally
disconnected data sources.
So to summarize,
knowledge mesh is this domain
centric data integration and
virtualization architecture
consisting of
a range of advanced
data management,
data processing,
data cataloging tools
working together,
to, to basically help automate
and help manage all the steps
required to build efficiently
build up to date
knowledge graphs
from disconnected distributed
data sources.
It, thus maximizes
the effectiveness
of data utilization
in knowledge
graph applications.
And, for those and perhaps
familiar with so called
FAIR principles,
principles basically,
adopted increasingly
adopted by
a large data intensive
enterprise.
Knowledge mesh is
really nothing
else but metadata first
architecture that is intended
and it allows to make
the data findable,
accessible, interpretable,
and reusable.
And with this,
I'd like to finish
and together with David,
take any questions
you might have.
Thank you for your attention.